so I thought me to something like we're
gonna talk about eventual consistency
which is the and why you know race
optimistic design you know so be moral
discussion
my name is christos pretty much anything
that's we extend so this is a quick
recap replication and consistency onset
so the sender's and eventually
consistent this means you're all your
data will get there eventually and
eventually is Noriko second in almost
all cases it is milliseconds it's not
micro seconds from so if for those
who've ever used you know you'll see
sometimes
you know seconds or even if you seven
counting the senators not like but it's
never going to take very long to get
replication now that being said
eccentric does have time to get
assistance if you say there's more
quorum is take a replication factor
divided by two plus one so you know at
least half of all okay we're getting
better you can also do a replication
factor that's that's really no one
people say people or is sweet spot it's
really not you're still waiting for
these two nodes to respond so during the
year in 2000 about rights going to a
master and then you scale down your
reads with with some slave databases
this was good because you're able to
scale out breeds scaling and especially
signals the Internet of Things website
wanting to millions of things a second
it's the right scale
really really looking but a lot of
people even when we had that single
master the replication for the slaves
always wasn't always guaranteed I've
seen many of a slave didn't get a
particular less and you know you have
this confidence that your slaves got it
they did in the industry playing States
for whatever reason Network pickups
whatever you can have steak and get lost
and now you've got slaves which are
inconsistent with your master well
Cassandra this coming to Center to but
Cassandra at least can repair this
cluster now what that does is it will
now start comparing records so even if
you've got all the tools out there to do
so
an iron of PAS to build those kind of
tools
Zappos does that iStockphoto Samantha
you send it they also they also have
this so it's not
but yeah some people that's what they'll
do to just replay on that and to the
slave as opposed to trusting that but
nothing school and then the point is
that even so everyone says I want
consistency with my reason rights just
like I haven't like bnsf well we saw
before that there was no guarantees so
so having a single master multiple
slaves whether you go through internally
there's always a way of possibly losing
I want my DVD to catch integrity issues
so I'm going to use Ruby on Rails here
or has used it before rails
if you actually look so they also don't
know cradles Grails these are all MVC
frameworks that allow you to prototype
monopolies quick and as we all know
prototypes and going to production and
then you got to scale them the issue
would not the issue but if you actually
look at the code generator underneath
there are creating any forms and as a
matter of fact one of the tricks I used
to use DBA was you know remove foreign
keys because then you're not checking
the referential integrity you're
increasing through yes you know one of
the problems is you don't catch
the site fast as opposed to you know
trying for perfection and the other
question is can I trust that the sender
will replicate my data even when I'm
writing a scale of 1 so let's address
that last so we didn't experiment
actually do go back there of the
appendix so we created a multimedia
Center cluster at the time it was one
one seven and it was 48 nodes in each
read operations per second when I mean
biggest center I mean so it give us easy
to us was to so we wrote a million
records and one of the data centers and
what we knew the blue records we read
them now interestingly enough we saw all
our million records there I shouldn't
have seen there the point I'm trying to
make is there will be a small percentage
that will make it over to the other side
and that's ok that's what we're going to
talk but in our particular case all the
records got coffee on the other side
this was and then again we were trying
to need any failure scenarios it was you
know both healthy so so you can trust
the center of that the majority in my
case all the majority of your
so even if my million records didn't
make it to the other side let's say nine
let's say let's say 0.1% didn't make it
on the other side or 0.1% so what's
gonna be the knee jerk reaction Oh
increase the consistency because I want
my stuff to be well what would that do
is immediately slow down your rights if
you really want to be consistent across
multiple data centers you're not even
going to do core across the rim and
that's how gonna be not in the
microseconds but possibly in the honey
microseconds if not one second if you're
if you need to go across a wire to
another data set you really want to
polish 99% of your users and their
experience for that one percent it's
nothing for me it's unfathomable then
you want to punish your users that
indeed 99% of your users for Mitch cases
so so you know higher consistency is is
higher latency and obviously diminished
user experience when when when you're
striving for higher resistance in an
optimistic design I want to I'm going to
trust that my data stores trust like a
Sandra
to get the majority of everything on the
other side and then nothin and if even
if it doesn't it eventually will because
it has built-in tools to then repair the
cluster notes to make sure what is there
what is the latest record oh I don't
have that I'm not going to get into the
mechanics but it's there it's very it's
very sophisticated and as I've studied a
lot other day of stores I'm surprised
how well how well it works at the center
so trust me we'll get there eventually
no business application always ask
yourself is it really that important now
I'm not here to say forget it
consistency is not good there will be
use cases you know your app you know
your product managers you know you know
your use case you need to make that
judgment whatever we want to get to here
is don't need your two full consistency
think about their problem so you can use
it so as you know you better play this
right so you add movies to your what we
used to call it you now call the play
list and used to your list and well what
happened is one percent of the time when
you chose that and will be to your list
it wasn't there
you'll refreshing and it will be fun
right so that happened one percent of
the time would you cancel your Netflix
subscription for that anyone know
that important so so in that particular
use case I can afford a little more
inconsistency there and you know next
time I'm ever maybe he reads this record
that there's also these two weeks in
December called read prepare so so a lot
of times that you read records Italy
circuitously fix stuff in the background
or there's an annual repairs you could
run on a specified interval and that's
what we mean by eventually eventual
isn't just the fact that it's
asynchronous it's also the fact that
there are tools within database to get
the whole clusters consistent again so
is it that important you only you that
only you can and alleged cases through
contingency plans and not all the
entities this contingency plans need to
be covered so let me give you an example
Amazon Amazon so some people would say
hey Norman retail you know my inventory
system has to be consistent like I can't
not give the right amount of widgets
that sell well Amazon believe it or not
has a bracelet eventual consistency even
in their inventory system sometimes
Amazon will sell you something that they
don't actually have an inventory because
at that moment you you were that one
percent that bought but along the water
and it wasn't any good but what does
Amazon do they say very next polite
email hey sorry who sold you this but we
don't have it anymore
oh and by the way here's the 10% credit
towards your next purchase so even in
retail through a contingency plan not
not necessarily through code you can
handle these kinds of use cases and in
some cases you can actually make money
with the division of assistance Thanks
banks have been and eventually
consistent
since the beginning of time anyone ever
write a check you write your paycheck
you cited there's no code there to make
sure that the money is in your ear in
your Italian and so on give it check to
somebody and one in two things will
happen
immediately the optimistic thing is I
believe the check and the check
representative money your widget or your
service or or whatever or thank you for
your point and but the check events if
there's not enough funds in the account
this is mrs. eventual consistency and
where's the bank do will they actually
chargeable people over the back of the
check bounced
actually that's true that's true
because because so why they were ferment
for a long time I worked in the bank
when I was studying through college back
in the morning and every bank ever every
branch had it's only been three so all
that all transactions were there at the
end of the night or batches sent out
really really checking if even the money
we gave out that's why sometimes bank
accounts are negative because they will
give money out without necessarily
without necessarily making sure at a
hundred percent consistency level that
there's enough funds I have I have seen
bank accounts for to my account too
sometimes
so the hurdles you'll face so you know
now I'm giving you you know hopefully
apprentice you up on eventual
consistency and I've sold you on it you
know what are the hurdles you're going
to face some of the hurdles are gonna
face are that you know try something
that to an engineer an engineer he knows
one thing one plus one equals two
not eventually two so a lot of times
even in systems where it's not that
important you know the engineers like
how much papa
you know I've gotten to the test here it
doesn't equal what I need it to equal
that it's failed and it doesn't get
deployed so so engineers I lovingly
include leather stubborn I'm an engineer
as well but you're gonna have to sell
them on it they're gonna have to adopt
new philosophies to the ways of thinking
about our technical applications the
management look a lot of people you know
some organizations you know management
is graded on uptime and an error that
low error rates and stuff like that
they're scared is this is what I'm
grading on so so they're going to be
often be roadblocks to be more open to
adopting the more optimistic design and
eventual consistency engage in product
non-engineers to get this better than
engineers especially the use case with
with the list right by like convincing a
product manager that paid one percent of
the time you might get at this but at
the next refresher within a couple hours
it'll all be fixed but that'll do
90% of all the other users this great
experience because it can be super fast
and so on for the best that's that's a
no-brainer that's that's again let's do
it
you know what percent we can add to that
so overcoming those hurdles
PLC's show them that show them the
percentage of time it'll actually it'll
actually go wrong you know we did one we
did one we showed that there was a
hundred percent of the right Scott over
there it's unfortunate that that
happened I would prefer not to percent
get there to prove my point but I Sandra
is fairly resilient and will replicate
you know we're with the pianist to show
the benefit to the user because at the
end every company's moving to this thing
where it's all about the user experience
even Microsoft this week everyone see
what they were talking about the last
week and Bill they you know everybody's
getting it's about the interviews we
want to give them the great experience
the best experience possible and of
course disco if you're working for the
wrong company questions yes some
clusters because some clusters would
embrace it well you know self-service
between equal one you can leave the
devices in the water
well that's the consistency yeah and
then and then clean up so that they
thought would be seat by so so the
question is
correct you're ready that's sealed and
that no one goes there but with your
records so see what doesn't he only were
writing to one no obviously it's always
writing to all your don't waste it's
just waiting for that first note to come
back and acknowledge it up right and and
then and then the application moves
spoke so I trust I trust that Sandra
will actually have that will has has
sent that data to more than one place
and so even if I was that no other reads
will end
remember the replicas other other nodes
in the replicas said cancer we couldn't
be any obviously knows yes but you can
read them to know that you Johnny
yeah you'll get that motivate are you
gonna stay out behind it up most reason
okay yeah that's right that's very
possible
and that's where you need to understand
your application can absorb tended
absorb them under sales
so anybody would have been living with
the exam alive at the place you just
removed you just you just added
something to your playlist so the worst
case scenario there you won't get you
know Avengers
your list until the whole repair stuff
hanger application in that particular
position so on that particular note and
that's very possible
can your application you know so I must
say never use I'm just saying
analyze your application see what the
worst case scenario is and then I just
start from the bottom up as opposed to
going from fully consistent
well then it's gone to three other well
they might not have enough time it's it
doesn't go to one then replicate to
others they would say it's a coordinator
that coordinator sends it to all
everyone's synchronous it just it's the
whole so our right pattern is you go to
the coordinator you give it a right it's
going to send it to everyone when the
consistency level does is you're
defining how many nodes need to respond
before I can then go back to the
application and declare that the right
was successful